un pompier de 24 ans est décédé hier
soir à Saint-Denis en luttant contre un
feu de voiture le jeune caporal chef
d'Orient damelancourt était en
intervention dans un parking souterrain
de la rue du Landy vers 3h du matin ce
lundi 3 juillet il luttait contre la
propagation d'un feu qui touchait
plusieurs véhicules et il a été
rapidement pris en charge par ses
collègues après un arrêt cardio
respiratoire mais malgré une
intervention rapide des secours il est
décédé deux heures plus tard à l'hôpital
des armées de Clamart Gérald Darmanin le
ministre de l'Intérieur a annoncé la
nouvelle dans un tweet ce lundi 3
juillet ajoutant qu'une enquête était en
cours pour déterminer les circonstances
de l'incendie né en juin 1999 le
caporal-chef avait été nommé sa peur de
première classe en avril 2020 après
s'être engagée à l'âge de 20 ans
titulaire de la médaille de la Défense
nationale échelon bronze il était
également engagé en tant que
sapeur-pompier volontaire en Savoie son
département de naissance à Saint-Denis
des habitants de l'immeuble avait senti
de la fumée vers 2h du matin mais les
logements n'ont pas été touchés une
source policière évoque quant à elle une
possible escroquerie à l'assurance mais
aucun lien formel n'a encore été établi
entre l'incendie sur lequel ce pompier
intervenait et les violences urbaines
qui agitent la France depuis la mort de
Naël 17 ans tué par un tir de policier à
Nanterre sachant qu'en 5 nuits d'émeutes
le ministère de l'Intérieur a
comptabilisé 5000 véhicules incendiés et
près de 1000 bâtiments brûlés ou
dégradés
[Musique]